we're going to talk about the four
biggest benefits of pistachios I realize
pistachios aren't really a true nut it's
a seed of a fruit but we're going to
talk about it today as an actual nut
because that's what people are used to
there's many benefits of pistachios but
there's four big ones number one out of
all the nuts and seeds it has some of
the lowest amounts of oxalates of any of
the nuts almonds have the most oxalates
so if you're sensitive to kidneys
stalin's for example or even arthritis
or even oxalates in general you would
want to consume pistachios or if you
have a history of kidney stones
pistachio is your go to nut all right
number two
very high in potassium we're always
trying to get more potassium loaded with
potassium good amount of phosphorus if
you've ever heard of something called
ATP that's the energy currency of the
body which is made in the mitochondria
that stands for adenosine triphosphate
so phosphorus gives you energy
zinc very important in over two to three
thousand enzymes so I think there's a
lot I've done tons of videos on that in
fact let me just put a link down below
because if you haven't seen some of the
videos I've done on zinc this one is
actually like a rock star it's one of
the most important minerals that you can
take okay
vitamin k1 will help if someone has
excess bleeding b6
very important in a lot of different
biochemical reactions also it can help
edema and swelling especially if
someone's pregnant and they're just
swelling up with fluid this can help b1
one of my favorite vitamins it reduces
anxiety it helps you sleep it helps
excessive thinking all the time 24/7
it's good for stress it's good for a lot
of things and then we have full-length
which is not just important in a growing
child to prevent birth defects but it's
also important and in dolt to prevent
breaks in your chromosome in your DNA so
it helps in the repair process if you
efficient you have all sorts of damage
in the DNA vitamin E vitamin E is a
important antioxidant but it does a lot
more it's very beneficial for your
muscles for hormones for your endocrine
glands and your skin also is vitamin C
and then chlorophyll which is like the
green stuff in a plant that's why I
pistachios are green because it has more
chlorophyll this is a good healer in
general and also for your inner skin
like anything going on like with
irritation on the inside of your
esophagus on down through your colon
this is very very important now in the
center of chlorophyll you have the
mineral magnesium so pistachios are high
in magnesium which is good for a lot of
things not just for muscle cramps and
sleeping and stress but also to make
energy and also to help with your heart
rhythm because it's one of the key
electrolytes alright number three it's a
good source amino acids it's a good
source of healthy fats it does contain
an omega-3 fatty acid called ala it does
have to be converted to DHA the active
form and EPA but still it has a good
amount of ala which is kind of a
precursor to the active forms of omega-3
fatty acids there's a lot of other fatty
acids that it has and those are also
good for many different things related
to cognitive function cardiovascular
function immune system and the list goes
on
also it's very little car so it's
perfect keto higher fat low carb medium
protein and number four antioxidants now
your body makes antioxidants you also
get them from your foods and so both of
them combined make up your network of
antioxidants to protect you from the
environment creating oxidation and free
radicals and also from your own body
making free radicals because that's kind
of a byproduct of the metabolic process
so antioxidants can greatly reduce the
complications of certain illnesses and
like diabetes for example that generates
a lot of free radicals
inflammation in general so these are
really good compounds and giving your
body additional health benefits that go
beyond just vitamins and minerals it has
the carotenes which are pre vitamin A
the cough rawls which is part of the
vitamin E complex and there's a lot more
as well some that even help with macular
degeneration all right there you have it
the four major health benefits of
pistachios hey if you're liking this
content please subscribe now and I will
actually keep you updated on future
videos